what's up everybody and welcome to
flager we're back okay listen we went to
Australia and uh you know Diddy was a
pillar of the community he had just
given his Masters back to all of his
artists yeah I mean he was in a
beautiful loving relationship Alex story
starting to sweat and adjust his seat he
doesn't know how to handle this topic we
come back from Australia Al
yeah something has gone a mck it is a
muck what is happened no this is all
allegedly this is all allegedly this is
said
alleged okay I'm just saying can you
fill us
in [__] out here so what happened with
Diddy and Cassie according to the New
York Times Diddy was out here ring up a
lot of people what ring up the community
I know we're not using a grape word I
say that I know we're not using a gra
word you you why you
laugh with all due respect with all du
respect what did I say that's a humorous
thing I these are facts reported by the
New York Times with all due respect all
due respect let's just be serious right
now and have a serious conversation cuz
this is an innocent man is innocent
until proven guilty this why are you so
nervous bro Alex more camo for this
reason no one's going to see no one's
going to see me come on you think just
cuz you dress like kid cudy you're going
to get your car blown up Happ is that
another allegation that's being thrown
at the diter yeah it is it is being
thrown thrown at the diter with all due
respect he not going to shave the side
of your head why you so nervous over
there bro everything going to be fine
everything's going to be fine maybe you
should just I'm I'm glad Cassie got
Justice there we go I'm glad she got
Justice what she didn't get Justice she
got money bro that's Justice talk to us
speak on that hair looks [__] good
thank you you look [__] you done blow
up bro I ain't gonna lie you know I'm
trying to get Diddy but um yo you think
this was Diddy Diddy pretended to be gay
so we wouldn't know about this like
pretend son for all those years the the
gay rumor was hovering so we never had
the grape rumor y oh all we heard about
was the gay rumor and gay is like root
beer like once you throw gay on it we
can't think of anything else we can't
taste anything else so he was all gay
now this gets thrown out obviously the
streets respect a little
more no they respect they respect the
weight of the allegations and they they
handle it with care and sincerity that's
what he means what do I mean say what I
mean the streets respected this D back
we ain't going
nowhere Ain we ain't
gay I think it's you ain't
go it was a royal Wii we [__] up on
that yeah now we got to look back at all
the songs a little you bad boy for life
that's it [__] okay now you're a
notorious cudy hater so are you yes you
are
you're the president of the hater Club
don't forget
this doesn't he do that when they ask
kid Cy for a common like did he blow up
your car that's what he did they did
that's how he communicates yeah exactly
all hums yeah he does are you glad he
blew up his car because first of all
yeah what I didn't know he was a Ki cuty
hater no I didn't know that oh my God
we're going to forget this which which
song kick push wish so kick push is fire
oh that was fire kick push close any way
we go yeah yeah
yeah way more SAR way we
go kick push coast and way we go a good
song just two lonely
Souls come on a good song words I don't
know push kick push coast and away we go
two lonely souls and we D big wait see
that's what I mean bro he's being
sarcastic I do know that's Lupe Fiasco
man you didn't know that
I I was waiting I was Wai for the turn
wait a minute he really don't know
asalam Alum uh Lup L Kum Lupe K Cy is if
you are what they say you
are
super come on that's also Lupe fias you
[__]
bony you don't know people to you don't
know people his
no he's like he's depressed in his room
right that's his [__] C night kid C's
day and night I'm on the pursuit of
happiness that [__] goes hard oh that
would that's I thought no he's the guy
that when he's performing ste's Neptunes
okay yeah you're right wait a minute
what's going on but Steve aoke throws
the cake at people he's a talented DJ
and his father started Benny hes MH kid
cudy is the ra that when he performs
there's a gravitational pull to objects
towards his head see oh y both got that
in common you had water bottles thrown
at you when did I have a water bottle
thr your way back in the day in edine r
that was a beer bottle no was water
threw a water bottle about oh that was
not on stage yeah I know that's just my
friend being an [__] you had a candle
thrown at you exactly you really wanted
us to remember that moment you had a
candle thrown at you by another com
really like we were talking about a way
different moment I just and then you
want to distract her with your shitty
throwing ability no it wasn't good you
didn't hit me I did I did no I did no no
I did no I did we could we we got the
take I think we should go back run back
we got to back run back to whatever I
said I I still believe it what I
whatever at least I wasn't just singing
one of my
hits okay no this was this was what I
ain't do the white boy humor yet and
suck my dick still meant something yo
suck my dick does mean something
right especially when sea puffy comb
said okay
allegedly y going to get listen what do
you think is going to happen n nothing
absolutely you seem no nothing's going
to happen you don't think anything's
going to happen you seem a little
frighten you seem a little concerned no
I just think he's going to try to make
an example out of someone and sue him
for
defamation well we're just saying things
that are in the art that New York Times
article is pretty in depth no I know but
it's like he's been defamed yeah yeah
but if you say because now we saying
this is all alleged as long as you say
alleged then we good can we go through
these allegations and understand these
are just allegations did he's an
innocent man matter of fact some might
say the fact that she was only going for
money and not actual justice justice
some might say that the motivation was
not Justice at all some might say that
she was maybe uh realizing that she had
come to the end of her earning potential
as an artist or Entertainer and was
looking for one last buck some might say
that Al wouldn't you why isn't money
Justice oh interesting point good
Counterpoint to be honest with you
that's a great [__] that sh needed a
beat
drop that sh
needed wow Manny fresh need to hit that
up yo that was crazy right there why
isn't it justice lowkey it is low key
you did something bad to me and I'm
suing you and now I got I think it's
Justice maybe for you but what about the
other people out there that could be
enduring those crimes that you're
accusing the gentleman of again this is
an allegation but now she put everybody
on you know like she made it up but once
she takes the money we go nah she just
wanted the money some people will but
also potentially women can be like oh
this is what this guy's accused of let
me at least steer clear you see what I'm
saying and other victims who can come
forward and I think also it's really
hard to prove guilt in a criminal case
especially this far after the fact like
there's no DNA evidence you probably
couldn't go when this guy's having your
MRI results of your MRI sent to him
first before you get to see them I how
do I trust that if I go try to get a r
kit first of all I'll even get to go
with this guy hold on hold on you're
being a little too
serious you getting a little too serious
about this we got keep it silly now got
can't go go can't go too far can't go
too far bring it back bring it back now
there's one thing learned is you can't
go too far you got you can't go too far
into the series we got to keep this this
light you know go take that take that
chill
out take that take that that's
crazy the signs were there man the signs
were there bro go to priz pi.com use a
promo code Schultz they'll match your
initial entry of $100 up to that $100 so
you put 100 they're going to match up to
100 exactly that's beautiful you said
that better than me now listen we in
this together we're Team okay we are
teams go to prize.com get that 100%
deposit match up to $10000 with the
promo code Schultz SZ you got this okay
now let's get back to the show